chadwick boseman has died at the age of
43
after a four-year battle with cancer
shortly after news broke
some of hollywood's biggest stars took
to social media to pay tribute to the
black panther star
brie larson tweeted that the actor was
someone who radiated power and peace
mark ruffalo wrote that he was one of
the all-time greats
chris evans shared several pics with his
friend on instagram
writing that chadwick was a true
original gabrielle union tweeted that
the late star was pure
excellence and class and grace oprah
called chadwick a gentle gifted soul
while don cheadle shared this pic on
twitter writing that he was
always light and love chris hemsworth
described
chadwick as one of the kindest most
genuine people he had ever met
while sterling k brown thanked him for
being a friend
kerry washington said the late star was
a warrior of light
till the very end in a statement to et
denzel washington called him a gentle
soul
and a brilliant artist and zoe zeldana
said he left a lasting
impression because of his energy poise
and gentle manner
other stars including chris pratt ryan
reynolds halle berry
joey king ashton kutcher octavia spencer
mandy moore aisha tyler zachary levi
tiffany haddish mariah carey and kate
hudson
also honored the late star on social
media while reese witherspoon tweeted
may god bless you and carry you home
news of chadwick's passing was announced
on his official social media accounts
friday
reading in part quote a true fighter
chadwick persevered through it all
and brought you many of the films you
have come to love so much
from marshall two to five bloods august
wilson's marines black bottom and
several more all were filmed during and
between
countless surgeries and chemotherapy he
died in his home
with his wife and family by his side
bozeman was perhaps best known for his
role as black panther in the marvel
cinematic universe this whole marvel
thing is just like it doesn't make any
sense like you feel like you're walking
around in a dream
he was set to star in the black panther
sequel which is set to hit theaters in
may
2022. this experience
you know it's hard to explain it uh
until you see it but this experience
will be
different than any other you've seen
that's for sure um
the themes the conflicts will be things
that
superhero films have never touched on
before
this cast is one that you've never seen
before marvel was brave enough to have
this
black cast mostly black cast so this is
an experience you've never seen before
for reasons i cannot even say
you